- I saw you did that happy
birthday post for your husband,
which is sweet, but I
thought this was cooler,
because I actually just saw
- Isn't he cute?
- Yeah, but look at to the right,
that's Barbra Streisand-
- I know.
- Yeah. She's just
commenting on your feed,
just like it's a day that ends in Y.
(audience laughs)
(Melissa laughs)
So like it's just, it's normal?
- When I see that I'm just like,
Ncaaw, when I wake up in the hospital
from my favorite dream.
And it's like, "I know Barbra Streisand."
And they're like, "You don't."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
I'll be like, "Okay,
it was a great dream."
But yeah, I see that.
And at first I thought, does
she thinks that (stutters).
At first I wondered, does
Barbra think I've had a child?
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
And then I was like,
that's really self-flattering
because I'm a hundred.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
And that woman knows that I'm not like,
"Oh, I hope I'm not pregnant."
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- No but what I thought was so cool too,
is I didn't see until recently,
I'm gonna mess up the title,
but it's something like;
"The Magic, The Memories, The Music".
She did this whole thing, this whole show
that I literally watched
through the night,
on Netflix, I believe it was,
but it was on TV,
and I had no idea about that
whole duet album she did.
The show was tremendous,
but then you did a song
with her on it as well.
- Which is also crazy.
- Not crazy, fucking awesome!-
- Oh yes!
But also when they called,
I literally was like, "No!".
First of all, I don't know
who this is.(Kelly Laughs)
Like my manager called and he's like,
Barbra Streisand wants
to do a duet with you.
I'm like, "What?
I think that's rude."
I don't know who's
punking me (Kelly laughs)
because I don't do that.
And then he was-
- Mean-spirited
I know, it was mean-spirited.
I'd do anything to meet her.
And then they're like,
"No, she really thinks you can
do it. Will you go meet her?
And what are you going to
say now?" I was like, "Yeah."
- Yes! Yes!-
- And she's great.
And I think the magic,
I think meeting her,
was already kind of surreal,
but then what I didn't,
there are certain people
that expect to be like,
"I am Barbra Streisand!"-
- Yeah
- It was like she would float in
on (Kelly laughs) a cashmere cloud
and just be like caviar and diamonds.
(Kelly laughs)
And she was so kind of like,
"Let's talk about how to make it better,
how can we work on it?"-
- Yeah
She was all process,
in a fun way.-
- Yeah.
But she still has the
love of what she's doing.
And it's still like, "How
do we do a little better?
What do you think?"
And I was like, "I'm not
telling you anything.
I'm certainly not going
to give you a note -
- A note.(Kelly laughs)
- She's like, "Do you like this or this?"
I'm like, "I like what you
like." (audience laughs)
And she's like, "That doesn't help me."
She's like, "Which way is better?"
And then I was like,
"I think the first (stutters)
way Barbra Streisand."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
And then once we got into it,
I realized she wants the note.
She wants to work collaboratively.
- Yeah.
- And I was like,
the fact that even at that level,
she's still like,
"let's work it out, Let's -
- Yeah
- And to me, that was the coolest part.
And she's really funny.
- Oh my gosh! You know, that's
what I thought was amazing.
Is she did this whole show.
That I saw and I thought,
"What a talented person,
what a gifted person,
what an exciting thing
to be still inspired."
Like, you know what I'm saying?
Still this many years later,
you see that whole career
that you're a part of.
You're a part of that career,
it's insane.-
- Bananas
- Anyway, I just happened to see it.
And I was like, she's all on your feet.
And I'm like, "Okay, I want
your life." (Melissa laughs)